I'm Sergey so today I'm going to talk
about uh patriotism
supplemented to Irvine State University
so basically it's not my bachelor to
this rather students who applied for
this topic
for GitHub
so first initially I'm going to talk
about shortly about guitar Club what is
it about then
I am going to talk about shortly about
basic operations in CNN's convolutionary
networks and then exactly to a topic
which is detective vehicles or from
satellite images
which was a bachelor thesis supplemented
by Arnold and I was supervising this
topic
so the guitar Club is a platform which
is enabling students
and supervisors to get together so
basically if you're a student and you
didn't find any interesting topic at
your University or faculty you will go
to guitar club and find some 70 topics
and the supervisors are next experts or
just practitioners in their fields who
does not who don't need to necessarily
be from the University so you can work
in machine learning topic and it can be
a machine learning engineer and you have
some fields of
research you want to understand you
write a short description in our topic
you submit to guitar club and the
students will see and they can apply to
your topic and if there is a match then
the guitar Club organizes the submission
protest to University so they
communicate with faculty and faculty
accepts this topic then you can write or
a student can write a visual thesis
which have been uh provided from
Outsider so non-university person
now I'm going to talk about the
convolution courses so first to
understand so basically on the top we
see a completion your network
which is consisting mainly of activation
convolutional maxwelling and activation
layers
and I would like to give a short intro
about convolution layer a convolution
filter
permission layer which is
somehow will bring you to understand
what is actually deep learning
so first you have a kernel which has
some parameters
and those parameters are uh
being tuned and adapted during our
learning process so basically your
convolutionary network during the
training process adapts those weights
and what is a convolution it is a kernel
linear combination over the patch and
of the import image and
the kernel
and the after linear when you calculate
the linear combination you replace n
times n image page
with one so basically you calculate the
linear combination and
aggregate the formation and provide this
to the next layer I'm currently not
talking about activation or maximum
nerves
and the thing is that the convolutional
filter of a next layer is going to run
uh
on already aggregated information
which is if I run over this image area
or this pixel this has been already
three times through pixel from previous
layer so basically this whole
information is packed into this one
in the next layer this yellow area will
act in the one pixel bit so basically if
I look through this one activation here
I would have a field of view of five
times five given the fact that I have a
filter of three times three
so what is happening that means each and
every next layer
sliding over an image page
which
where each pixel has been a separate
image but in the previous layer so
basically I'm aggregating cortex
information
that means in initial layers I'm going
to detect maybe very vertical or
horizontal vertical edges in the next
layer I'm going more to take the
combination of those
so the deeper I go
the higher is the abstraction
information and the strong semantic
information I'm going to detect
the thing is
which is increasingly receptacle so the
thing is this increases to get it larger
to have a greater receptor field you
need to have a lot of layers more layers
more parameters which might lead to
overfitting the network
so how to come to address this issue one
of the approaches is
um to the max pulling layers so this Max
point there is a filter which is running
over the image usually it is a filter of
2 times 2 and the step of two which is
running sliding over the image and
picking up
um
from every page
an active activation with the highest
intensity so from this I'm going to take
the six from the other one eight and I'm
going to have a smaller activation map
but which is containing for me let's say
the relevant information I lose some
information yes I lose the rest frame
but I am I am but reducing the
activation map twice in each Dimension
so basically this is good for
computational costs because I'm reducing
the activation map but
at the same time I am increasing
the context information so basically to
understand if you are in a museum and
you are in front of a painting like if
you just sit directly in front of
heading maybe 30 centimeters above you
won't understand what is it you might
slide your head over a printing to
understand what is it but what you
usually do you take a step back and
understand what you see here so
basically in order to have the view of
the object or of a scenery at once
or if I would like to ask you hey if I
would point a hand in front of you and
ask what you see in front of you and you
don't know what is depict what is in
front of the kind of object in front of
you instead of sliding your head over
the mobile phone which you are not aware
of priori what is it would do like this
take a step back
and to have
to see the object at once so this is
basically one of the
uh
features of Max filling layers but I'm
going to talk about later so what you
see here is actually this is a
convolutional neural network
receptive field with
uh with low receptive and greater
receptivity why it is important because
if we have a if we fit to the network to
the decision maker
what is depicted here for the network it
could be easier to understand what is
depicted here when it sees the whole
object with the context information
rather than see a small rectangle which
is covering a part of a car so this is
the importance of receptive field and
uh
and also maximum layers and convolution
layers
so now I'm going to talk about the topic
which is to detect vehicles from
satellite data from satellite
so basically we have 32 000 labels
labeled vehicles
the images are done captured from six
distinct locations
and the resolution at Grant is uh one
pixel for 15 centimeters so basically
every pixel are is a 15 centimeter uh in
the real world so basically if my car
has the length on average three meters
then I will see the colors in the image
my cars will have uh dimensions of 20
times 20 pixels in the images
we splitted the data into first
validation test and train set
and we made sure that our validation
test data has variation in locations
and the imagerial is resolution varies
from 2K to 18ks
and I'm going it will show what kind of
problems with faced
um the thing is the images are large and
we cannot take a an image of size 18 000
times 18 000 pixels into Network so what
we basically do we just
slide over the image
we pick thousand times thousand pitches
and take this to a network there is one
thing to understand is that
uh this step is 800 pixels so basically
I make sure that I have my current and
the previous page has overlap of 200
pixels so that we don't miss the cars on
the borders of two edges
and one thing this has been done by
students better student and he also
spent 20 years 20 years old so he had
made research so what I'm presenting you
is supplemented by a student so I was
just
supervising and giving some suggestions
so we decided to use retina net
architecture
why because those are ought to be good
in detecting small objects as I have
told our objects are has the size of 20
times 20 pixels and we need to have a
network which is our meta architecture
which is capable of
dealing with small objects in the
previous slide I talked about Knox
polymers when I was saying I'm reducing
the image resolution or activation map
the thing is if the object initially has
a size of 200 pixels after five layers
it will be a four four pixels so it will
be hard for your network
from the last year to localize the
object and detect it
that is why we decided for retina met
and now I'm going to explain what is
behind it behind the retina net is the
feature pyramid Network architecture
so basically if you can see this is a
bottom app flow where we see the image
Aggregates or extract features
aggregate information by running
convolutional Max builders
and then in the end our image will be
much smaller than the initial size but
the smaller objects are going to be
small
so it will be complicated for us to run
detection over a small encoding
information or activation map
okay in fact that I'm going to detect
small objects
so for that reason
but here I have strong semantic
information if I mentioned we are
aggregating strong cement information
and features
so how to use both basically to have
finer information as it is in earlier
days shallower layers and also strong
semantic information so what fpn
proposed is just
to have two ways bottom up and top down
once we reach the bottom up once we
reach the last layer
we try to reconstruct the encoding
information
but at the same time
and we run free predictions free set of
predictions so basically in the last
layer I'm running predictions
and after reconstructing up sampling the
image I'm again running predictions and
we do it three times
what is important to understand is that
despite that we reconstruct the strong
semantic information we also with
lateral connections
uh fuse the information from earlier
this
where I had information about edges more
finding for finer information I am
fusing with strong semantic information
which is enabling us to detect small
objects so that's the concept of feature
pyramid Network it's meta architecture
which is used in written on it
any questions so far
so this with the performance we've
reached is
feature pyramid Networks
yeah so
oh no the whole method called name is
Retina net the arc retina net which is
using the concept of Feature Feature
pyramid Network architecture so you you
might have a different backbone you
might have some
different other heads but the concept of
this is the feature pyramid Network
where you
reconstruct the information from some
strong semantic information fusing with
layers from earlier stages
so yeah uh
yeah so my question basically was that
in the right bottom uh embedding will
basically the whole meaning is that will
basically have the information from the
like really small objects as well as
from the big objects or it's yeah so
basically yes so but yeah so
in this layer what you guys what we are
going to the next smaller or larger
objects
uh they're larger yeah and here middle
and here smaller yeah right so
uh yes you can actually detect larger
objects here as well but usually what
you do you do anchor based approach and
you place anchors and you replace larger
ones and hero plus smaller ones right so
combine them yeah you'll combine them
yeah at the end of course you combine
them yeah
you're running very non-maxim
suppression
what we thought also in Russia we see
it's done in six weeks which was very
short time period but what we could also
maybe we just get rid of these two
predictions because we are going to
detect only small objects
so
for example in this part we actually
what what is bad here is that I mean
like we run predictions at the earlier
stages where we don't have information
of strong semantic information like
we're here
so there are some methods which are
running predictions already from the
beginning
yeah
so yeah we approached the weighted
Precision recall of 95 and 96 percent
respectively
and basically
there is a backbone we throw with
freezer backbone and we train the head
of a network
and uh so
what we've done also in the we're
trained
during the 11 first 11 epochs we trained
with original data and the rest up to
15th Epoch we trained with augmented
that way as well
and we've we've seen that when we use
augmented data directly from the
beginning this is how effective
negatively with the performance however
an initial Trend with original data and
then with augmented data of fine-tune
augmented data it brings us performance
Improvement
so these are some examples
here you see with blue color with
correct detections of cars vehicles
the red rectangles are false positives
where there is no well maybe it's not we
don't maybe here for example red ones
are detections where there is no car but
we think there is a detection that
network is very detection and the yellow
ones are the vehicles which are not
detectable
um yellow can you see here
yeah here in this area
so we're
I hope this video will work yeah so this
is
this is not real time working for
speaking but just to see on the Clone
video how it is performing
and you might see false positives as
well here in ventilation shafts also
White
why because in our yeah
so you say that's not real time but
what's the size of your model and do you
have any estimation if you want to apply
it in that
like in a real-time application how much
delay will you will have you know
maximum or something like that
so we don't have it it took part on on
two RTX 270
it took about two seconds per frame
and you ask how is the potential to
reduce it
well we didn't think about the real time
working with current our Focus was a
performance so once in a new wherever it
will be students will continue to work
on this and we reach we see we reach the
best approach on the performance plan
will start to think about
making it real time so that's not our
Focus currently
but the other three ways a lot of ways
to use
but the strategy is what you usually do
you just reach the best performance you
can and when you start to shrink your
network
pre you know quantize the parameters
about yeah two seconds on this YouTube
yeah this is a mobile on the notebook
frame so it's not like a professional or
yeah so have you tried to optimizing it
no uh not for on time currently
um so what I what just analysis what
we've seen in our trading data set we
have seen a lot
objects so
so in majority of training data with
white cars
we have cars which are dense close
together we have cars
and that's why sometimes we we have a
lot of false voted on ventilation shafts
and
also here there is some Shadows it's not
visible here but color variation on the
image and it is next to a lady broadly
so basically in our Network thinks that
there is a detection here
well our assumption is that once we have
Lanes
and there's some color variation it is
somehow hinting the network saying hey
there is a car because majority of our
training set we have cars close to Lanes
we have dense we have the tech cars
where we have a lot our cars appear with
our cars together so if you don't major
really have separate cars in the field
or on the road you have a lot of cars so
somehow presence of a car painting a
network there might be a car as well in
I'll put it in other words if there is
one car on the road this will reduce the
confidence of a network if there is a
car because there is no car surroundings
because our Network context information
is full of cars close together
so what we are suggesting to do in the
future
so basically we suggest as a future work
to apply different augmentation
techniques
so cut off cut mix augmentation you
basically take one image and take an
hour image different
you crop A vehicle part or a real
vehicles and place in the hour image
so that our network will boost the
environment it won't perform detection
based on the environment and if you have
problems of detecting
Soul cars sold cars in the field you
might overcome this if you place for
example your car cropped car in some
area where there is no car and run so
basically you create synthetic data to
make your neural network robust to some
environmental situations
um
uh to we also suggest to apply
artificial Shadows on the image create
some synthetic data
and one also approaches those key Point
detectors so basically not a bonding box
or having a key point which is going to
cover the Contour of a car
because if a car is somehow diagonally
then you're going to
place a bonding box over it which is not
optimal and we also do we do not detect
trucks here because very large on
proportions
so that's why to use keypoint might
overcome the issues of course we need
also to label it
yeah so guitar Club so if you are
interested feel free to apply students
supervisors but I'm not officially
representing the attack Club but I made
this
and this is my contacts
yeah that's it
questions
so uh basically I bombed into uh this
thing I'm not quite uh like
understanding but I thought that like
for optimizing the whole thing maybe the
quantization will help I don't know if
you are familiar with that could you
like explain why it can help why it
cannot help
um well of course once we have a final
results I mean the best approach
quantization will help quantization is
basically your
and imagine you have
so basically the information or which
kernel which I was showing
uh are so certainly float 32 bits
yeah so there were no integers or not in
integral numbers and for for each num
you need 42 bits or maybe 16 bits based
on the equation but once you have your
results
once you know how your final now weight
parameters of your final Network
you might
say you might
sample your numbers to some specific
range which you can encode in with eight
bits
yeah that's that's a thing so once you
know the range of your data range of the
parameters and the values of your weight
you might sample in that way so that you
will have specific range which you can
encode in 8-bit instead of 42 bits
you just need to like try and see which
uh like how much will you reduce to have
like minimum loss of the accuracy yeah
you might do also like yeah for example
I mean is there like kind of formula or
something to like determine what uh
percentage of reduction of the like
weights will uh cause the like minimum
accuracy lost or it's just like trying
their thing uh I'm cannot say exactly
but I guess it's more trailer error and
also there are some libraries
uh
libraries which are doing is it for you
automatically so basically they also re
reduce you can also reduce also channels
so for example you have convolutional
filters of Secrets each each layer has a
solution protesters might be from 128
from 64. so you what you might do is
like
refer 64 layers convolution filters in
each layer that doesn't necessarily mean
that each of us learn something you
might there are some layers which will
not bring anything so you can prune
those just get rid of those
and this is more traditional so just get
rid of us you capture the L1 or L2 norm
and if you see based on a value some
threshold you say this filter doesn't
hurt anything so if I get rid of this it
does not have no impact on my
performance and you can do this further
evaluate and see
what can you do in order to optimize
reduce number of channels and also not
to have a large loss in your accuracy
I see thank you yeah
and for quantization there are some
formulas which are one-to-one so
basically they might not reduce the
performance as much but
um yeah it's it might be mostly the
church to talk discussing yeah
technically
um you can also try the tensor RT
technique yeah which is which has really
good tools for especially the
convolutional neural networks to
optimize it and have much faster
prediction
so they're also I guess using some
layers together basically this is really
amazing I've never tried on my own but
this is do this job automatically it's
automatically
oh no no no oh I mean some layers are
not supported but uh you can try it on
different layers as well not on
convolutional so I wanted to ask if you
used any their preprocessing uh before
uh going before like inputting it to the
neural network no we didn't use any
pre-processing
maybe you're reducing the noise reducing
the Shadows would help much better than
making the data more yeah and feed it so
we have vegetable layers we had
normalization also in the input but with
standard deviation standard
normalization but we didn't do any
length
reducing Shadow also please I don't know
HSP space Power space and didn't do it
okay thank
you
and did you use a pre-trained retina net
when you started the training we just
pretended the back one was pre-trained
on coke satellite images I guess from
open data set
and also you train it with vocal loss
yes and yeah basically losses for
classification but we have a task or one
plus actually so somehow but we use for
the internet that way yeah so I cannot
talk about Oculus we don't have
classification tasks
but there are the ones we have a second
class which will have affected us but
the focalo is also one of the
uh
important
features of retina
thanks
[Applause]